my goal for us is that we can give talks
and they can be intelligent and elevated
and we can talk about machine learning
and how our models worked but hopefully
we can also talk about what the data we
used is how we got it into a structure
that we could work with and kind of you
know how we deal with these unstructured
data sets or how we deal with these
unnormalized data sets so regardless of
if you're in academia or the industry I
feel like we're dealing with a lot of
these messy data problems silently or
just by saying after I process the data
then I was able to train this model so
sometimes I feel like I'm the only one
with unnormalized data and everybody
else has this amazing normalized data so
could you raise your hand if you've
dealt with normalized data within the
past year that was completely normal
okay in the past six months keep your
hand up in the past one month keep your
hand up okay so this is a problem so I
know I'm not alone a simple search on
Stack Overflow for really any type of
data wrangling or data cleaning topic
shows that yes there are tens of
thousands of people with these same
problems and so I feel like we need to
embrace these problems and have
conversations about them I mean you're
all here but we have to worry about the
people out there so the first step in
terms of determining messy data and what
to do with it is knowing your data if
you're working within your domain and
your domain expert then you probably
already know a lot of this but let's say
you're dealing with a new data set or
let's say that you switch industries or
you're working with a new team you might
need to ask some really big questions
about the data you want to know the data
source you want to know the methodology
how is it collected what are the likely
values what are values that might bring
you pause these are all things that you
have to have a conversation about before
you dive into data analysis
you need to know is it been has it been
normalized
should it be normalized right if you're
looking over you know say
measurements collected over the past 10
years and it has anything to do with
currency or it has anything to do with
any other variables that might have
changed over time then you have to start
thinking about these questions how am I
going to standardize the data how am I
going to normalize it and also ask
yourself questions what's significant if
I find that there's more sunglasses sold
in the summer time that might not be a
significant data point depending on what
I'm trying to ask so I found this geek
and poke comic and for me it was funny
and what I think I'm trying to say here
is you should know what's relevant and
what's significant and sometimes they're
not the same thing but also you know ask
yourself questions it doesn't matter
that it hasn't gone above 100 percent in
this case no right so focusing on what's
relevant will help keep you focused on
what to clean and how to deal with these
messy data sets so one of the biggest
problems that you'll face when dealing
with either under structured data or
unstructured data is that you have
missing data so once you've cleaned it
and you pulled it together you find out
that there's no values or that you're
missing significant data points this
could mean that you wanted to collect
all the data points for the EU and let's
say you're missing Germany that's going
to be a problem for your analysis if
you're also missing critical data points
for your exact question so say you have
80% of the data collected but the 20%
that's missing is actually dealing with
the question that you wanted to answer
that's also going to be a problem and
then if you're dealing with missing data
so you have time series is there a way
that you can fill in the data so using
pandas or a lot of other different tools
for data analysis you can choose to
backfill Ford fill or fill with some
sort of value if you're dealing with
these
situations that might be the best bet so
when you're dealing with missing data
you need to know the possible null
values if you find that say 10% of your
data set is the same exact number and
that number is not a likely value then
it's likely that that might be a hidden
null value so if you don't know the
origin of your data or how it was
collected then beware of those odd or
strange values if all of the values are
a bunch of nines or a bunch of zeros or
something like that that might signify
something and when you're cleaning your
data keep an eye on statistical
significance so if your goal is to
answer a question with a particular
piece of your data or with a few
different values and say look at their
correlation and you end up with you know
only 20% of your original data set
represented you may have essentially
cleaned your way out of being able to
answer that question so another problem
that we often face with messy data is
duplicated data and so you should know
again you should be a domain expert or
you should know when potentially you're
dealing with duplicates so it could be
that you yourself inserted the problem
into the data set so you did some batch
processing you ended up bringing in one
batch twice that's a problem that you
created right it may also be that
whoever collected the data for you did
something like that so know which
duplicates are intentional so I wanted
three different data points for this
particular time stamp and know which
ones are likely human error you also
might need to determine your own unique
keys so depending on the data set I've
done a lot of work with government data
sets and sometimes they have an ID field
and you feel like ah this should be easy
this is my unique and that's just not
the case it ends up that that ID field
represents you know that particular time
point in the survey and there's actually
three of them because there was three
different locations where this survey
was given
so know about how to create unique keys
or groupings you can also utilize the D
dupe library so this is a library that
tries to match essentially messy strings
and match them together so it can match
potentially 32 kilometers with 32 km
this is the goal of that library and you
can also use fuzzy matching so who here
has used fuzzy wuzzy by sea geek it's a
really useful library that essentially
measures string distance and therefore
is is great for dealing with say
misspelled data or when you're dealing
with user input data so you can also
when you're dealing with user input data
or survey data have inaccurate data so I
don't know how many times I let chrome
autofill something or this or that and
it's an address of some place I lived at
2-3 years ago so these are problems that
you have when you have users inputting
data it could be bad values could be
inaccurate zip codes let's say or
incorrect country codes your data could
also just be out of date so Julia Evans
mentioned yesterday that you know
depending on how you're how often you
update your data you could have
inaccurate DNS records so Dilbert is one
of my favorite comics and this is a
situation that I can relate to and so
basically in this situation you're
dealing with inaccurate data and for
whatever reason the data is wrong and I
think that this is a situation hopefully
you can also relate to or you've been in
similarly and it's about being able to
have a conversation if you're the
manager then being able to ask questions
well why is the state of false why do we
still have it in a database somewhere
how can we make it more accurate right
and if you're the engineer in this
situation then potentially it's about
informing you know managing up if you
will and it's about informing other
teams that you work with hey the data
collection methods were using for this
measurement are inaccurate and false and
we should do something about it
messy strings are potentially the worst
thing about being a Python data Wrangler
and they're all over the place I have a
long history in web scraping and if
you've scraped any data yourself then
you know that there's a difference
between actually having your scraped
data and being able to accurately apply
it and so having the data and having the
data in a form that you can ingest it
and do analysis are two different things
again
fuzzy matching indeed you can help with
these I know that everybody hates regex
or maybe not everybody but I feel like
the people that love it might just have
Stockholm Syndrome or be perl developers
or something like that but everybody
hates regex at the same time it can be
really useful so if I know I need to
pull out a phone number from this string
and it's somewhere there I usually turn
to regex
so it can help I would not say that it's
for every problem but it can help for
the problems that is good at if you know
what data types you can expect then this
can help a lot too so if I know that I'm
expecting floats and I'm seeing strings
then I know that I have something that I
need to clean up and determine what you
really need so if you're dealing with
really messy strings or unstructured
data in string format then determine
what you actually really really should
work for and determine what can just go
by the wayside you don't need to clean
everything right so encoding woes this
has been a problem for a long time if
you're using Python 3 I hope it's less
of a problem for you if you're using
Python 2 still I highly recommend
importing Unicode literals I'm sorry for
the Celine Dion refre reference but
hopefully it won't be stuck in your head
for the next two hours but this this
Unicode code byte is here to represent a
heart emoji
so I asked Ned Batchelder if I could use
one of my favorite slides about Unicode
and it's this I say embrace the Unicode
sandwich and for that reason you need to
know all the entry and exit points of
your code for any sort of data i/o and
you need to know if if you're building a
library that handles i/o for me then I'm
expecting to hand off Unicode to you and
I'm expecting to get Unicode back if
you're not a library maintainer then you
should be expecting the same thing right
and if you're not getting that then a
you should be filing a bug with the
maintainer but B you should also make
sure that you correct for that so it's
about knowing all of those entry and
exit points and make sure that you're
using Unicode on the inside and bytes on
the outside and you can do this
regardless of your python version so
another lovely topic is dealing with
measurements and metrics so I hope since
I'm in Germany that most of you are
dealing with actual metric data but how
many of you have to deal with data sets
that are sometimes Imperial No okay
that's amazing well I'm sorry for you so
regardless of the data measurements you
may have data sets that have more than
one type of metric used or more than one
type of units so you should know that
you should know what values you plan on
doing your analysis in and you should
determine how to reach that standard
before you get knee-deep in data
analysis and so think about how you can
convert how you can standardize and make
sure that you make notations of how that
was done
because if other people are trying to
replicate your research or replicate
your analysis they're gonna need to know
hey by the way I chose this one standard
I converted all of my data to it and
then I moved on from there this
a comic I found about about outliers
I've been shabad he's a grad student
somewhere and I found it both funny and
relatable so on the topic of outliers
yes I know that the standard practice is
we need to remove them so that we can
find the overall trend or we need to
remove them so that we can do actual
real data analysis but I'm also a big
fan of determining when is the outlier
actually important when am I let's say
overfitting when am I just choosing or
inserting my own biases on my data set
and determining naana this line is great
I don't care about these ones that don't
fit so if you're going to remove
outliers take a moment to actually look
at them first and determine is there a
story here is there something here
that's significant and if so sometimes
that can actually be the focus of your
data analysis rather than whatever it
was that you initially imagined it being
so if you're dealing with funny file
formats how many people here have to
deal with PDFs or audio files or video
files it's not exactly as bad as it used
to be so I recall talking with folks
years ago at a conference about using
using basically Linux system libraries
to try to compile audio and and
necessarily like find interesting pieces
in the audio by using system tools we're
obviously very much further than that
that said AI and machine learning are
not necessarily always the best tools
but they have developed quite a lot of
things for us if you're dealing with
funny formats if you're dealing with
PDFs I mentioned them and showed a
little bit about PDF tables at mine
tutorial yesterday but I highly
recommend it it's not yet ported to PI 3
but it does actually work for
for extracting PDFs or sorry extracting
tables from your PDFs PDF miner is also
really useful and it has a PDF to text
tool if you just need the text from the
PDF then that's what I would recommend
doing and text racked deals with PDFs
and a bunch of different data formats so
if you're dealing with images I've read
a few good things about author opus and
there's a bunch of free OCR api's so
I've dealt with this problem a little
bit in the scraping world and I find
that quite a few of the api's work very
well if you're dealing with speech then
the speech recognition library I highly
recommend what it does is it gives you
basically a simple client interface
where you can talk with either ibm's
watson a bunch of the google speech
api's as well as a few different other
ones I believe Bing is in there
represented but you can get speech to
text really easily with that and has
anybody taken a look at take note for me
if not you should
it's a project by Cyndi Wang and she's a
insight fellow studying theoretical
physics and she built it it basically it
takes YouTube videos or really any video
that's a professor writing at a
blackboard and it uses image processing
I believe she actually uses scikit-learn
to pull just the text and take the notes
for you so it's pretty neat right now I
think it mainly works on blackboard like
black based but I think she said she was
working also on a white board option I
highly recommend taking a look it's fun
just to play around with even if you're
not a physicist beyond that I think that
one of the biggest pieces is using
common sense so if you have a data set
and it says that a man is pregnant
you need to ask yourself is this making
sense or is this data possibly wrong if
you're looking at a data set
and it's normalized or it has a normal
distribution and you are expecting that
not to happen then you need to decide
has it's been pre processed is this data
wrong so you can always check these
types of things I recommend doing a
quick histogram and other things when
you first import your data and check
also for correlations you expect to see
so if you correlate height and weight
and you see that's completely off then
is the data properly collected or maybe
do you have the measurements right so if
you expect to see some of these
correlations or if you expect to see
different correlations then you might
want to take a look at those first
before you begin to use your data set so
speaking of correlation and causation
this is a fun xkcd comic so if you use
common sense with your findings
you're gonna determine when say it's a
population map or when your data is say
over representing for something like
simple numbers and when it's not biased
right so you you need to make some
conclusions by using your brain using
what you know and applying that to your
data by answering these questions you
can determine can I still use this data
set which you probably can but do you
need to maybe think about how your the
population Mike skew the way that your
data was collected so before you draw
massive conclusions from it you needed
to determine okay how is my data
collected is it over representing and
answer those questions first so in
preparation for this talk I decided to
do to try and consume as much messy data
as I could find and in doing so I also
decided to read some academic studies
and I drove into recent papers recent in
academia by that I mean
2013 and up and I found a lot of
interesting things one thing that I
found is that not or unsurprising to us
as it should be many many different
parts of academia are now applying
machine learning concepts to messy data
sets and they're actually getting really
really great results so there's some
really interesting papers out there and
great ways to look at implementing
machine learning and data cleaning as
well as applying functional constraints
to your data sets as a way of solving
this problem magically so if you're
already using say like an enterprise
data wrangling tool or an enterprise
data warehouse I don't know what you're
paying for it but probably some of this
is actually already happening for you if
you're not doing that then the good news
is is that it's very very quickly on the
way so this is a graphic from continuous
data cleaning which was one of my
favorite papers that I read it was by
volkl's Chang slits and Miller and it
was published in 2014 and what they
decided to do is they had a series of
functional constraints so this is
essentially saying something like
there's a zip code and it just maps to
one city and by applying these different
functional constraints then they can
flag when data doesn't fit when data
doesn't fit then they can learn class of
a can use classifiers to make repair
type predictions and they use a cost
model as well to decide is this repair
costly or not is it going to require me
to clean ten rows or just one row then
it makes decisions on that and
recommends repairs to the user now this
is an interesting part and this greatly
greatly increased their likelihood of
getting it correct they then used the
user input data so the user says okay
this looks right or that looks right
then with that data they were able to
retrain the classifier using this
approach they were able to reach 90%
accuracy so I think that this is
something that's on the her
if not actively being used and for that
reason I believe some of the people who
wrote this paper are working for IBM now
but I do think that this is something
that we could also try within the PI
data community good to try and determine
what are the functional constraints for
our data set how can we then map them
and determine is my constraint broken or
is the data broken and how can we then
apply machine learning and use machine
learning algorithms and advancement to
make this even better so I want to say
thanks I know it's a bit short but if
you have any questions you can either
ask now or you can reach out if you're
interested in a little more of the
papers that I was reading about then I
can also pass them along to you you can
find me at K Jam on both github and
Twitter and you can also find me at KJ
and Stan comm I also really really love
talking about messy data so if you have
a particularly messy data set that you
want me to take a look at or that you're
willing to share then that's a favorite
pastime of mine so thank you
thank you very much Catherine um any
questions
thank you very much for your talk it was
really enlightening can you recommend
any good libraries for detecting unknown
encoding of files yeah so that's a big
problem obviously uh what I would say or
my first advice is is to attempt I have
several things that just attempt the ten
most common encoding that I see that's I
think probably the best way you can test
for the Unicode or you sorry you can
test for the UTF start byte is a lot of
times how I do that as well and there is
a new way in Python three I would have
to look at the exact name of the
documentation but there's something that
tries to magically guess the really hard
thing about this is that there are code
points that are represented in numerous
encodings that are different so you've
probably experienced this as well where
you think or it has a code point that
match maps to this and then you find
later that it's actually been decoded
improperly so I think that there's no
magic yet I would say that with a few
intelligent guesses you can usually get
it down to three or four different
possibilities but from there I think
applying some of the common sense of
what's likely depending on the origin of
the file what's most likely is usually
the best way okay thank you very much no
problem other questions I would like
maybe to ask you to tell about
particular data set that you were
working with that the cleanup turned to
be either insightful or surprising yeah
so same yeah of course so I worked with
quite a few data sets when I was writing
I wrote a book for O'Reilly on data
wrangling in doing so I worked with a
lot of different data sets a lot of them
were government data sets they were
really messy and awful and a lot of
times I spent hours and hours cleaning
them only to find that there was
absolutely no correlation between the
two things I was trying to take a look
at so I probably went through
twenty or thirty different data sets on
a variety of social indicators in Africa
trying to find links between certain
social factors and other social problems
and found absolutely nothing so I
eventually found something that was
dealt with government corruption
allowing for an increase in violence and
and that was the link I finally found
but what I'm trying to say is most of
cleaning data is a lot of unthankful
work just thankful for yourself that you
got through it but at the end usually
you'll find something that makes sense
so stick with it as a company and in
your experience which are some of the
techniques and the practices that you
could put in place to prevent ingesting
like the messy data or producing messy
data yeah so hopefully if you're
producing the undated that you're
consuming you can have some influence on
what's actually produced but if you
can't or say it's another team or it's
just messy log data then I would say
that pre-processing is key so before you
go ahead and store your data see how you
can optimize in a performance friendly
way about pre-processing my data in some
way shape or form so for example with
high spark with streaming you could do
some cleaning depending on how
performant your Python code is you could
do that before you actually send it to
Hadoop or wherever you're storing your
data so I would say the biggest problem
that I see that people have is they've
stored all this data somewhere and
nobody bothered to pre-process it nobody
bothered to post-process it see this
massive database or this massive data
set of really messy data and if somebody
had just taken time to even just do some
simple string parsing before it went
into the database then there wouldn't be
this problem right and once it's already
in the database then it's a whole other
problem trying to extract it and clean
it and reinsert it right so depending
especially if you're dealing with
production systems try to implement a
solution sooner rather than later
that gives you data that you can
actually work with and this might mean
yes like messing around in production
with things that you don't necessarily
want to touch hopefully you have a good
staging environment or something else
represented of the data that you're
processing but I would recommend overall
just focusing on pre-processing it and
focusing on making that as performant as
possible I just wanted to ask you
whether you have any experience with
Apache tikka for text extraction from
documents so I have not used that I have
heard mixed results but I haven't tried
to use it for eyes I think that probably
the biggest problem in PDF or text
extraction from PDF like documents is
not the text itself but it's the other
things right it's like the images the
charts or the tables that are the most
difficult because when you pull that out
via some sort of image recognition or
when you try to locate those using the
actual PDF miner tools to locate them
it's often just like really unintuitive
I would say and so yeah if you have good
experience have you used it yourself
or yeah I just found that there are
Python bindings for it and that it
around a bit with it but just for text
and not anything else like you mentioned
yeah so I think it text is kind of a
solved problem with PDFs right now which
is great it's more I feel like the very
unsolved bit is getting tables getting
data out of tables and other things like
that or images particularly difficult
but I'm really hoping that kind of the
with the speeds that we're moving in
terms of image recognition and image
processing that that will just become a
thing I can say on page 37 there's this
great chart please extract it for me and
the image the image processing libraries
that we're getting can then do that
basically from a PNG or something like
that
okay so if there are no more questions
so thank you again